because did you only put out seven shots
in the Harry Fraud [__] last year yeah
yeah count them you're right yeah right
you know what I'm saying this year I got
a few things lined up like I said I got
Gunsmoke I just dropped uh me and Conway
got an album oh crazy okay yeah the
people gotta get ready for that is it
finished it's done oh man yeah that's
coming I'm gonna follow up after
Gunsmoke with that so y'all heard that
do you have a title for it oh you're
gonna need a lighter again aren't you
yeah I'm gonna need the lighter again
let's get this wonderful Jardine lighter
yes sir
so yeah that's coming the name of that
album is called special Machinery oh
yeah something serious special Machinery
yeah we on there getting busy and [__]
you know what I'm saying I produced the
whole joint me and my me and my guy
Jimmy Dukes he's a producer from out of
Buffalo we we produced the whole joint
oh and uh how many songs
ten ten oh yeah 10 joins me and Conway
dumping going crazy yeah and I feel like
last year Conway kind of like
he had a great year he did drum work
Fest and stuff but I feel like he kind
of kicked back on releasing music in a
normal pace so I know this year he is
not playing yeah he's been loading up
him and Jay skis just dropped I know his
album comes out in April
when is do you know what date you guys
are dropping this uh for July August oh
[__] you know what I'm saying I'm gonna
hit him one more time one more solo
before the year out yeah you know what
I'm saying so I'm gonna give them three
projects this year I feel like you just
celebrated the anniversary of the album
with Benny and I made me feel like damn
time flies was it five years it was five
years man and uh we actually on a low
wheat and we in the studio right now
cooking you and Benny right now a part
two yeah yeah and it sounds like damn
man it's surprising to hit a hunger that
we still got right like it's like wow we
still sound this good together and we
still you know I'm saying we bring the
best at each other so one of my favorite
album covers too appreciate that
starting shot two is on the way y'all
y'all get ready for that man so that
might come this year too it's a strong
possibility if not it's definitely
coming next year yeah you ain't playing
bruh nah this guy is not playing I'm in
my bag right now you know what I'm
saying a hundred percent man so
um what is the difference between doing
an entire project
with Benny which you've already done
you're currently working now and then
getting in with Conway do they have a
big difference in terms of just how they
worked it like like well yeah yeah it's
a difference because like Conway is more
late than anybody well he's the latest
guy alive what you mean like he just be
like I'll be there at 10 but he comes in
like you know that's my brother I love
Conway
but um yeah it's definitely different
and [__] me and Ben you know we was
recording for a longer period of time
right you know what I'm saying we've
been doing this [__] for together for a
long time yeah since like 0.708 right
probably oh six so you guys had a lot
more we got a lot more chemistry yeah of
course you know what I'm saying uh me
and Conway we ain't record as much but
we still got history and [__] but you
know um the recording process is still
really like the same though we still go
in there and give it our best yeah it's
a very competitive situation it's a good
way a room it's a great anytime like you
know me and the spit is just a few
spitters right that I [__] with anytime
we get together it's a very competitive
situation you know what I'm saying and
it brings out the best so you know y'all
expect to hear some great [__] that's
correct special Machinery yeah I like
that man that's gonna be hard 10 records
yeah any features
yeah we got Lloyd Banks on there come on
man yeah man I got dropping so much just
news just
yeah man I got Lloyd Banks on the hill
we got Pharaoh Mantra on there does
anyone ever tell you look like Pharaoh
launch a little bit oh we're a little
bit just a little bit just a little bit
Pharaoh much didn't have hair right I
could see it
Pharaoh Manchester is one of them ones
though that's the homie he's one of them
ones and you don't hear his name enough
when we talk about like the greats
Pharaoh March is one of them guys
yeah so you know that [__] is coming
back like you know upload it though man
upload it you ain't playing this year